airline fernsehformat hdtv wird ihnen
präsentiert von swiss ein gästehaus auf
der insel bali patricia und romano julie
wollen aus dem alltag ausbrechen familie
volk sie sucht ihr glück in kanada in
den rocky mountains bauen sie ein
holzfäller unternehmen auf tobias bayer
und michael paris wollen endlich etwas
eigenes eine kleine bar auf weite
ventura
[Musik]
auf fuerteventura im einkaufszentrum l
campana rio haben die bauarbeiten in der
bar von tobias bayer und michael paris
endlich begonnen
sechs wochen später als geplant wieder
bestens
die auswanderer sind mit ihrem bauführer
silvio verabredet er hat den auftrag
übernommen und soll dafür sorgen dass
die handwerker pünktlich fertig werden
und sorgfältig arbeiten dass da ist für
die discokugel aber es ist nicht die
zentrum
ja das ist für die kugel die kette ist
nicht in der mitte
in der mitte ja dann hängen wir sie um
das einzige positive nachricht ist das
herzstück
in der letzten folge warteten tobias und
michael vergeblich auf den beginn der
bauarbeiten nichts
nach langer suche konnten sie endlich
eine passende wohnung finden über den
preis waren sie sich noch nicht einig
nach sieben wochen trennung kam patricia
endlich in ihrer neuen heimat auf bali
an
nun muss sie sich den herausforderungen
des neuen lebens stellen
[Musik]
in kanada angekommen aber familie volk
ist noch ohne hausrat und maschinen
die erste überraschung ließ nicht lange
auf sich warten
[Musik]
so hat sich auswanderer christian volk
den start in kanada nicht vorgestellt
seit zehn tagen erst wohnte mit seiner
familie im neuen heim
[Musik]
ich bin es tatum selben muss eben
abwasserschacht hockt
[Musik]
hier haben christian und sein
mitarbeiter mirko vor kurzem den
wohnwagen an die abwasserleitung
angeschlossen sei aber ich weiß dass ich
jetzt die scheiße durchweg putze mir ein
der flug so wie ich dadurch steckt um
mark eingestellt
du bist du so ein spiel aber zweimal
geschafft
und das ist da wo ist da dürfen wir hier
wieder oder gar nicht so schnell aber
nicht mit der hand von solchen großen
stinkt gemachte zeit zum fremd nein das
war nicht ein großer stinkt das war die
dummheit von mirko und papa ja ja ja es
macht aber kein ja das ist nicht so
der schweizer hätte frühjahr wenn so
etwas passiert den ruf stimme und dem
der kunden und den kader das mache und
dort war machen wir klar sei aber
einfach ja
[Musik]
offenheit die kamera beim wegwerfen war
die breite des portfolios an die steht
voll in der scheiße die will ich nicht
mehr
[Musik]
auch im tropenparadies kämpfen die
auswanderer mit anfangsschwierigkeiten
romano trudi und seine frau patricia
haben ihr gästehaus pro 4 wochen
eröffnet zudem haben schon ist das haus
überteuert gemietet jetzt versuchen sie
den mietpreis zu senken
doch die verhandlungen stocken ein
weiteres problem sie haben von den
behörden auch noch nicht die lizenz
erhalten ihre unterkunft als offizielles
gästehaus zu vermarkten
dabei haben sie mit liebe investiert den
garten neu bepflanzt die fassade
renoviert zimmer gestrichen neue möbel
gekauft und klimaanlagen eingebaut haben
wir wirklich jetzt lucky einzeln putzt
will es im prinzip ist so schön sich
jetzt haben es einfach so gemacht
mit unserer möglichkeiten was zu einer
vertriebs rasch machen aber es ist nicht
niveau sport
[Musik]
bald schließen baut haben gemacht was
machen wir jetzt
danke das war's also machen wir jetzt
machen muss hat das falsch oder richtig
bereits das mache skateboard gut so
hallo schlimmste szenario war ja wenn
jetzt gar nicht gut nord mio bevor denn
wirklich tolle ankündigen
dann müssten wir die schweiz aber das
ist für mich jetzt noch nicht so schnell
simulierte zerstört
ich glaube der war monicelli zu legen
bis probieren das über acht statt wie
[Musik]
gäste hierher bringen
dies müssen erst noch den richtigen dreh
dafür finden
[Musik]
im zentrum von corralejo haben tobias
bayer und michael paris endlich ihre
wohnung gefunden
der indische besitzer ist ihnen im preis
entgegen gekommen und hat ihnen die vier
zimmer wohnung möbliert für ein jahr
überlassen statt 750 euro zahlen sie nur
650 pro monat der indische familie
zwölf jahre lang verließ und mit trend
und trikot und trinken sie an gegen die
der boden käse angeboten
ja die haie anschieben
dass ich zeit wichtig sie sehen die luft
immer noch besorgt oder bezugsrechten an
sind alles sehr am herzen
vor zwei wochen konnten sie die wohnung
beziehen jetzt nutzen sie jede freie
minute um sich hier wohnlich
einzurichten sowie offiziell auch und
ich nehme heute berater wohnungs putz
hin oder her
sie haben einen termin mit bauführer
silvio vereinbart tobias will erreichen
dass die bauarbeiten vier tage früher
fertig sind denn ihr budget von 30000
franken schmilzt mit jedem tag überhaupt
nichts was es nicht besser ringo starr
unbedacht überspringen
[Musik]
so schnell wie möglich von tobias und
michael in ihrer bar gäste bewirten nur
bauführer silvio hat momentan auch noch
eine eigene baustelle die bodega seine
frau auch diese bodega steht kurz vor
der eröffnung
also wenn ich dann wieder dürfen erster
juni dann würde wer ist da schon wieder
hat daher mitarbeiter alles verbaut da
muss ich nicht für mich
die bot der faz
es wird der regen verhinderte
tobias muss jetzt den chef markieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schönes wochenende gehabt ja viel los
[Gelächter]
ich gehe davon aus dass in einer woche
alles fertig ist
so hätten wir zwei drei tage mehr zeit
die möbel und die flaschen einzuräumen
und zu reinigen
die eröffnung ist am freitag den 27 wir
haben noch viel viel arbeit besonders
mit der elektrik aber trotzdem glaube
ich dass wir das bis zur eröffnung
schaffen können
so oder so ich werde druck machen kein
problem
ihr könnt mit dem 27 rechnen das
gespräch verlief besser als erwartet
tobias konnte vier tage rausschlagen
ob der bauführer tatsächlich wort hält
[Musik]
laut und deutlich reden die sommerferien
in clearwater sind zu ende und die
schule fängt an
auch für zorn der sechsjährige startet
in der vorschulklasse einfach sorgen
wenn man sich nicht recht findet aber
über die hälfe dem ja die wüsste er dass
er es nicht aber es scheint seine witze
die club gemacht
wohin führt das buch deshalb auch erst
mal wieder seine zeit bis man sich
gewöhnt dass er halt jetzt diebe stunden
am tag vacation aber im test definitiv
gut wenn er immer wieder geweckt
wenn du aufs klo muss teile genau dann
wissen die alle roten muss aufs klo
simone fährt ihren sohn zur schule
bald wird er die zehn kilometer lange
strecke mit dem bus allein zurücklegen
müssen
hast du es vergessen spd glaubt nervöser
wird schon an der schule werden 300
kinder aus der ganzen region
unterrichtet ab jetzt muss ich schon
alleine behaupten schon kennt bisher
keinen seiner mission
auch seine lehrerin hat er nur einmal
kurz gesehen
[Musik]
in u boot am anderen ende der welt geht
patricia den start in den tag gemütlich
an
seit etwa zwei monaten lebt sie mit
romano nicht mehr im hotel sondern in
einer gemieteten villa ein paar hundert
meter von ihrem gästehaus entfernt so
richtig die hsbc
[Musik]
es sieht weiterhin schlecht aus mit den
buchungen die zimmer konnten sie bisher
nur auf einem online marktplatz für
privatunterkünfte inserieren
neben rund 1000 anderen angeboten allein
in obhut und umgebung und problem ist
wie wir sind zu oft gescholten haben
können aber über fremd der findet uns
einfach nicht irgendwem raubte geld
verdienen und wo du machst du dir schon
gedanken ans herz legen oder was und wie
viel besseren oder was ist grund
schließlich dank ist mir eigentlich
immer das probieren kann die höheren zum
probieren ein
[Musik]
was patrizier und romano benötigen wäre
der zugang zu einer großen
internationalen buchungsplattform aber
das ist nur möglich mit der offiziellen
lizenz für gästehäuser diese immer noch
nicht bekommen haben
um nicht ganz auf der stelle zu treten
haben die beiden flyer entworfen
ich habe ihnen heute morgen eine e mail
gesendet die flyer sind fertig doch kein
ersatz für wirksame internet werbung für
uns wir das so genannte porto bis auf
damit haben dürfen wir nicht andere
plattformen wie booking.com expedia und
war wie es ja die heiße nutzer sie
machen sie erstanden die kontrolle von
der behörde wahrheit lizenzen waren und
war nicht
und wenn wir sie nicht hätten verlief so
wie sie alle sind inzwischen
rausgerissen oft ausgegangen
jetzt müssten sie eigentlich vollgas
geben aber ohne die lizenz bleibt ihnen
nur ein aushang im größten supermarkt
von butt
[Musik]
in kanada hat christian volk seinen
ersten auftrag er soll ein waldstück im
steilen gelände roten 4000 kubikmeter
holz jetzt wo es losgeht hat christian
einen weiteren mitarbeiter eingestellt
er erklärt dem wie sie vorgehen werden
vom sägewerk bereits heute genau woche
über der holzschlag wir das machen
hinter dem wir machen jetzt aber alles
fertig wie stark sich für das normale
verfahren wie sie sind dieser schlag ist
für kanadische verhältnisse eher klein
für schweizer dagegen riesig fast
zehnmal so groß wie christians bisherige
aufträge das bedeutet arbeit für
mindestens fünf wochen
[Musik]
links und rechts den berg oben schaffen
die männer kennzeichnen die fahrwege
sowie die bäume an denen sie die
tonnenschweren holz erntemaschinen
befestigen können
das löse das ist günstig und effizient
schulze und ich sehe nicht ein warum das
war nicht gut
christian und seine männer sind bereit
fehlen nur noch die holzernte maschinen
die immer noch unterwegs sind
vertrauen ist gut kontrolle besser
um eltern bei mario steht die nächste
baustellenbesichtigung an
tobias und michael wollen sehen ob sie
sich auf ihren bauführer verlassen
können
und siehe da der elektriker hat schon
angefangen und zwar um eine panische mf
der siebte da ist das ja ja ich denke
die lassen
[Musik]
früher nachmittag in clearwater simone
und christian holen gemeinsam ihren sohn
an die schule hat für die neuen schüler
und ihre eltern ein fest organisiert
heute ist der erste tag fertig und jetzt
gibt's anscheinend die pickel bekommen
back to school picknick und es waren
momente john cusack und weiß doch
passiert erzählt und dann haben wir
wollen ihn wartet ist dass endlich ruhe
kommt für sechs lange stunden musste
simone ihren sohn allein lassen
sechs stunden in denen schon
zurechtkommen musste ohne ein wort
englisch zu können wir alle miteinander
ich glaube die touristen stehen nehmen
und hast du ein bisschen verstanden die
leute oder gar nicht daran kann es gar
nicht
also ja gesagt ja schon ganz viele neue
leute gelernt
die familie aus der schweiz ist einer
unter vielen
christian und simone müssten auf andere
zugehen doch das fällt ihnen schwerer
als gedacht habe mir gar nicht bewusst
welche das b klasse irgendwann schwierig
dass deine ganze kinder sind ja was sind
schon ja
[Musik]
johnny hat bereits anschluss gefunden
auch wird der ventura haben tobias und
michael schon den nächsten termin in
einer druckerei haben sie aufkleber und
bilder mit dem logo der bar bestellt die
sticker sind fertig die aufkleber wollen
sie verkaufen
mit den bildern dekorieren sie die bar
sie bekommen einen zentralen platz
[Musik]
sosehr erste werbekampagne schulden der
stadt wusste ich dass ich nur dazu raten
mit 2 1
überleben die behörden ich bin ganz froh
dass er so richtig weh
30 schüler sind sagt uns jetzt die guten
stücke nur noch heil nach hause bringen
gleich geschafft
[Musik]
der stern in pink ist der favorit cool
ja tobias trägt die sterne sogar auf
seinem arm gar nicht irgendwie straight
grad irgendwie logisch dass das kind im
zusammenhang mit der freinacht für den
arbeitsstress punkt wo man vielleicht
mal
[Musik]
das ist so komme ich ja
auf bali haben romano und seine frau
patricia mehr zeit als ihnen lieb ist
ohne gäste haben sie nicht viel zu tun
danke schön schön blöd ich hab mich
nicht getraut zu holen beim malen kann
patricia entspannen
ihr liebstes hobby seit vielen jahren
die farben hat sie extra aus der schweiz
mitgebracht und den niederrhein macht ja
und das hat sich dank
sieht immer alles so konstant ist mit
geht mit
die ungewissheit zehrt an den nerven
eine schwierige phase für patricia in
der schweiz gab die 56-jährige den ton
an und führte als bereichsleiterin ein
team von acht mitarbeitern
hier ist sie von anderen abhängig
[Musik]
romano hingegen lässt sich treiben er
vertraut einfach darauf dass sie bald
die notwendige lizenz für air bed and
breakfast von den behörden bekommen und
dann auch gäste
ich möchte manchmal so vor mir schlafen
dieser moment jetzt macht es mir viel
mehr zahlen
[Musik]
ich wurde für das von jetzt der kh trial
und bin ich zufrieden
[Musik]
auch in kanada sind den volks die hände
gebunden
die holzernte maschinen sind immer noch
nicht da und ihr privat container mit
dem hausrat ist ebenfalls nicht
angekommen sie versuchen sich abzulenken
und machen einen ausflug so und schon
geht mit den männern angeln simone
bleibt allein zurück
die reine gar keine störung war nicht
gekommen ist kann er so viel sie ist
quasi dass die maschine vor der lange
überfahrt salzwasser shatterhand das
dass jede zweite verschoben für deine
maschine marot wurde ich da gibt's alle
setzt sich derzeit wollen wir gerne tree
und sich eigentlich schönsten sind es
doch einfach zum abo coaches schön
[Musik]
die jungs brennen darauf die angeln
auszuprobieren die sie von der
vorbesitzerin beim hauskauf übernommen
haben
[Musik]
das modell dieses kinos kommt ist genau
dadurch wird aber ich kann menschen
ihren ruhm
doch auch funktionieren
[Musik]
wunderschönes wetter
wiederholt
[Musik]
traum von der eigenen bar im
inselparadies für tobias und michael
rückte mit jedem tag ein stückchen näher
sie verteilen einladungen für die
eröffnung
nächster stopp die wohnanlage in der sie
die ersten wochen verbrachten
[Musik]
letztendlich mit 42 jahren wollen wir
keine songs machen danke hallo wir
kommen nur schnell mit der einladung für
unsere eröffnung
falls sie zeit haben wir eröffnen am
mittwoch den ersten juni herzlichen dank
und auch makler jan olov der ihnen die
wohnung vermittelt hat bekommt eine
einladung und der nachbarin
dann noch ein abstecher zur konkurrenz
steht ein messer gerade die bodega von
silvius frau wird heute eingeweiht
bauführer sie berio für einmal ganz
privat
er ist kubaner und kam vor neun jahren
nach fuerteventura
vielen dank für die einladung
ich habe hier eine kleinigkeit schweizer
schokolade danke vielmals schweizer
schokolade
die stimmung ist ausgelassen und im
lokal gibt es kaum noch einen freien
platz
die auswanderer sind fast ein wenig
neidisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die beiden testen den mojito auch bei
ihnen wir dieser cocktail auf der
getränkekarte stehen
[Musik]
silvio und seiner frau ist die
einweihungsparty gelungen werden tobias
und michael mit ihrer paar genauso
erfolgreich sein
[Musik]
er zieht es gemacht karte ich mache das
alte denken
besondere anlässe benötigen besondere
vorbereitung bis heute in st man muss
doch
die familie des landbesitzers hat für
studis eine balinesische opferzeremonie
organisiert landbesitz amadé auf dessen
grund und boden das gästehaus steht
überwacht die vorbereitungen persönlich
[Musik]
die opfergaben sollen die götter und
dämonen milde stimmen
das ist alles im klang soll sie mit
guten und schlechten ton versucht
[Musik]
aber schön ich es schon für genug
bekommen
[Musik]
feuer wasser und blumen gehören zu jeder
opfergabe auf bali alltägliches ritual
der rauch trägt die essenz der opfergabe
zu den bietern
[Musik]
gratis ist der segen der götter freilich
nicht
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
umgerechnet 50 franken muss romano
bezahlen
ein wenig göttliche unterstützung können
dies tatsächlich gut gebrauchen
ein verregneter nachmittag in kanada
endlich hat sich der zoll in tacoma bei
christian wegen der holzernte maschinen
gemeldet
der amerikanische kunde dass die raupen
doch kontaminiert sind mit schmutz und
jetzt sind jetzt moment eher
spezialfirma hat und die reiniger und
dämonen vom agrarministerium eine
untergeordnete zu europa tag genau vor
der lounge bar gesteck standard daher
könne die hamburg maschine landete aber
in haiti sind aber irgendwie
einzelakteure alles zusammen so thomas
jetzt aber gar nicht vorstellen wie das
immer unter kilometer weit fahren
na ja und da war nix in der nächsten
folge christian richtet ein schnitter
für zum paradies kriegt und ehefrau
simone hadert mit dem neuen leben
das ist ein schwieriger widersetzte
vorgestellten trifft einfach nicht
wirklich viel
zeit für plan b moody's kommen auf
stippvisite in die schweiz
sie versuchen ein neues geschäftsfeld
aufzubauen und endspurt auf fette
ventura der traum von der eigenen bar
wird für michael und tobias konkret aber
ausgerechnet dann plagen tobias
zahnschmerzen
du musst nicht die gerne willkommen
immerhin musste
ruf des urhebers neuester hin
sid
[Musik]
er präsentiert wurde